you don't have to study physics for very
long to meet the fundamental constants
of nature things like the speed of light
planck's constant boltzmann's constant
gravitational constant
and these numbers pin down the way that
the universe is structured
they're very important because if any
one of these numbers was even a few
percent different
the universe probably wouldn't exist and
we wouldn't exist
to experience them so i thought cool
video would be for me to try
and go out and find all of these
physical constants and collect them
together in one video for you to see
and this is the story of me doing that
but what's interesting is the final list
doesn't actually contain any of the
constants that we're familiar with
it doesn't contain the speed of light
planck's constant gravitational constant
none of them it contains another set of
numbers
which are more fundamental and even more
fascinating
so to find out what the heck is going on
keep watching
so first of all we have to start off in
a familiar place with the formulas of
physics that we've encountered before
things like the gravitational force
between two bodies
equals mc squared the energy of a photon
and also the force between two charges
all of these equations contain one of
the physical constants
and we need to know the precise value of
those constants in order to solve the
equations
so let's take a closer look at one of
them so this is the speed of light it's
precisely 299
792 458 meters
per second precisely and it's kind of
weird that this number is this
precise you'd think if you were
measuring the speed of light you'd have
an
error bar on the final number there
but this makes sense when you realize
that we actually use this value of the
speed of light
to define our length of the meter and
it's a sensible thing to do because what
we know or what we believe
is that the speed of light is a fixed
value everywhere in the universe for all
time so it doesn't matter who measures
it
they'll measure the same thing so we may
as well say that that thing
is a fixed number and then what we do is
we say
well we've got this length of a meter so
the distance that light travels in one
second
is exactly this many meters we measure
the speed of light
and then that sets the size of the meter
and in fact since 2019 this is the exact
principle which we use to define
all of the si units so the unit of time
a second is based on a transition of a
cesium atom which should be the same
no matter where you are in the universe
obviously the meter is defined by the
speed of light
we've also got electrical current is
defined by the charge on an electron
and the unit of temperature is defined
by
boltzmann's constant mass is defined by
planck's constant
and so on this means that we've defined
all of these
physical constants to be definite values
when we measure them we've pushed all of
the errors in those measurement
onto our units so our definition of a
meter is only as accurate as our ability
to measure the speed of light which
lots of people do and we've measured it
to great accuracy
[Music]
so where are we on my quest to find all
of the fundamental constants in physics
well we've learned something a bit
troubling there's actually nothing
special about this value for the speed
of light
because it depends solely on the units
that we're choosing for our meter and
our second
for example in cgs units the speed of
light is a hundred times bigger because
we use
centimeters instead of meters so
scientists like to use the si units
as a convention to make sure that we're
all on the same page when we do
calculations and work on space missions
but there's nothing special about that
specific set of units
it's just human convention so if we
didn't use those we could actually pick
our unit of length
and our unit of time to be sizes where
the speed of light actually equals one
or boltzmann's constant planck's
constant gravitational constant
they all equal one these are called
natural units instead of si units and
this specific choice of physical
constants to be equal to
one is called planck units not to be
confused with planck's constant it was
the same dude but
different things and i've put the
equivalent si units so instead of a
meter
we now have the planck length and that's
a very small value
the planck mass and the planck time are
very very small and the planck
temperature is very
big physicists use these units in
nuclear physics particle physics and
quantum gravity mostly to make the
equations a bit simpler for example
with these units because the speed of
light is equal to one e equals m c
squared just becomes e equals m and the
energy of a photon instead of being e
equals h bar omega just becomes e equals
omega
but this is weird right just by changing
the choice of our units we've actually
changed the equations of physics
we set speed of light equal to one and
it just disappears
well not quite we actually have to be
very careful to keep track of the speed
of light
it's still there it's just equal to one
and this reveals something deep about
the roles that these physical constants
play
in our equations of physics and to see
why
we need to look at the dimensions
let's go back to our old faithful
equation e equals m c squared and what i
want to do is look at the dimensions in
this equation and by dimensions i don't
mean
like the three dimensions of space i
mean the dimensions we use in physics
the physics use of the term which is for
those physical quantities we can measure
like
length time mass temperature the things
we need units for
so the m in this equation has got the
dimension of mass
it doesn't matter what units whether we
use kilograms or pounds
it just needs to be a mass the speed of
light has obviously got dimensions of
length over time
and the units of energy are mass times
length squared over time
squared and for an equation in physics
to make sense the units on both sides of
the equation
need to equal out this is why in our
natural units
these equations look so wrong because e
equals m
is basically saying energy is equivalent
to mass
which we know doesn't make sense when we
look at the dimensions
and so when the speed of light is equal
to one it still needs to
be there because it needs to take care
of those dimensions
and this tells us something deep about
the role that these physical constants
play in our equations of physics
they're conversion factors that show us
how
certain physical quantities relate to
other ones so the speed of light tells
us how mass
is related to energy planck's constant
tells us how
frequency is related to energy
boltzmann's constant tells us how
temperature is related to energy and the
gravitational
constant tells us how mass is related to
length
so here's here's the big picture
between every physical quantity mass
and time or energy in time or mass
and length there'll be a physical
constant between them to tie them
together
and the actual value of those physical
constants is not very important because
it's dependent solely on our choice of
units
but what is important are the
relationships
between the sizes of those physical
constants the ratio between those
constants
because those ratios between all the
constants
is what sets the particular framework of
this
universe the recipe that makes this
universe
stable so is there some parameter some
number that captures
the relationships between all of these
different physical quantities
some some number that describes some
deep
feature of our universe well yes there
is
it's called the fine structure constant
and it's dimensionless
here is the fine structure constant
alpha you can see its relationship
between
four of our physical constants the
electric constant
speed of light planck's constant and the
elementary charge
the actual value of this is
approximately equal to one over 137
but the actual value is slightly smaller
than that and what's cool about this
number is
that all of the dimensions on the right
hand side actually
cancel out so this is a dimensionless
number it doesn't matter what unit
system you measure it in you'll reach
the exact same number we've got no
idea why it's this precise number
the origin of this constant comes from
studying the atomic spectra of hydrogen
it's the electron orbitals doing their
thing but as soon as you add in
relativistic
effects you get a splitting of energy
levels called a fine structure splitting
hence the name find structure constant
but since then we've realized that this
constant is actually more general and
more fundamental
and now it forms a core part of the
theory of quantum electrodynamics
which is the theory that unites
electromagnetism quantum physics and
special relativity
and the phone structure constant sets
the strength of the interaction between
electrons and photons so this number
the specific way is kind of sets our
entire experience of the world
everything we touch and feel is mediated
by electrostatic forces
and everything we see is from light
so if this number was any different our
experience of the universe would be
completely different
in fact the universe probably wouldn't
exist
and this is a puzzle that's been
challenging theoretical physicists for a
very long time
feynman called this the greatest damn
mystery in physics it's a magic
number his words and
the reason is the universe just gives us
this number and there's no underlying
theoretical
framework to tell us why it is this
specific value
also this is a brilliant number to send
to aliens
to prove that you're intelligent all you
have to do is say
one over one three seven and those
aliens know immediately that you know
electromagnetism quantum physics and
special relativity
although probably best to send it as a
binary number instead of in base 10
because they've probably got
i don't know 11 fingers or something
so now we've got to a true universal
fundamental
dimensionless physical constant and this
is the reason why we don't include the
speed of light
planck's constant gravitational constant
as fundamental constants because they're
not
dimensionless so the question is is the
fine structure constantly only one or
are there others
well there are others in fact there's a
total of
26 that set the
structure of our universe so let's take
a look at those
[Music]
so this final set of universal
dimensionless constants
is given to us by our best theories of
physics a combination of the standard
model of particle physics
and also general relativity now most of
these numbers
25 of them come from the standard model
there's only one number that comes from
general
relativity and that's the cosmological
constant
this is the energy density of empty
space
otherwise known as the vacuum energy and
it's closely related to the expansion of
space
what we call dark energy even though we
don't really know what dark energy is
but we have
measured it pretty accurately moving on
to the standard model which you can see
here
this is just all of the different
particles in the standard model
now 15 of these dimensionless physical
constants come simply from the masses
of the particles that have mass and
they're the mass in kilograms divided by
the planck mass to give us a
dimensionless constant
then we have a thing called the
electromagnetic coupling constant
but this is actually just another name
for the fine structure constant so we've
already met this
there's also another coupling constant
that sets the strength of the nucleus
strong force
so we add that in there would also be
one for the nuclear weak force but we
can actually
derive that from the other constant so
we don't need to include it
on our list so that gives us 18 of our
fundamental dimensionless physical
constants 26 in total so we've got eight
left
the final eight come from interactions
of the fundamental particles with each
other
and i'll be honest i don't fully
understand the underlying physics of
these but i'll
i'll tell you as much as i know four of
these numbers come from
the interaction of the w boson with the
quarks
in something called the this matrix
giving you four parameters that define
those interactions
and then you get another four parameters
from the higgs boson
interacting with the neutrinos in the
this
matrix but we're really hitting the
limits of our knowledge about physics
here because there's still lots of
things we don't understand
about neutrinos like how they get their
mass
and other things to do with their
handedness and whether they're their own
anti-particles so this
set of numbers might change in the
future based on new physical theories or
new evidence
in fact theoretical physicists would
love to be able to get
this set of fundamental constants down
to a smaller set
but to do that we'll need some
revolution in
the foundations of physics we need some
new fundamental physical theory
that would explain why these numbers
are the way that they are so we finally
did it we got to the final set of
universal dimensionless constants that
the laws of physics
gives us quite why they are the specific
numbers that they are
is still a complete mystery if you've
got
any ideas leave them in the comments
below i'd love to hear your thoughts
and thanks for coming along on this
journey with me i hope it's been
enlightening i'm aware that the
destination might be a bit more
abstract and hard to understand than we
were anticipating when we set out
but i've linked to all of my original
source material in the description below
so if you want to dig deeper on your own
that's a great place to start
and i'd like to tell you about the
sponsor of this part of the video
brilliant
if you want to learn something new
brilliant is the place to do it
brilliant a website an
app that makes learning accessible and
fun and is an excellent way to dive
deeper into the subjects in my videos
their approach is based on problem
solving and active learning
seeing concepts visually and interacting
with them and then answering questions
that get you to think their courses are
laid out like a story and broken down
into pieces so that you can tackle them
a little bit at a time
there are no exams or grades just pick a
course based on what you're interested
in
and you can happily make mistakes
getting help from the explanations
under each problem there's something for
everybody whether you want to brush up
on the basics of algebra
learn programming or learn about
cutting-edge topics like quantum
computing
just go to brilliant.org dos or click on
the link in the description below
which lets them know that you've come
from my channel
and yeah thanks again for watching and
i'll see you on the next video
which i'll be posting pretty soon
thanks bye
i think it's good how you can just sit
in your kitchen
and think about physics and go on a sort
of
journey through the nature of reality
[Music]
it's cool takes your mind off things
anyway